measuring a Quantum superposition is as random as flipping a coin but how far can we take that
analogy before it breaks down we'll find out today on kiss in the
classroom welcome to kiss in the classroom a video series where we break down a fundamental concept that you
might encounter in a Quantum Computing related course each video is accompanied by an interactive module Linked In the
description below so be sure to check that out today we're talking about one of the core principles at the heart of
quantum theory superposition in our everyday experience objects always have definite features their location size
shape color everything about them is determined and certain even if we The Observer haven't yet measured it in the
quantum world this isn't necessarily the case a Quantum object can be in something called a superposition of
multiple class Al allowed states which when it's measured will randomly collapse to one of those
States measuring a superposition state is like flipping a coin there's no way to know ahead of time which way it'll
land this fundamental indeterminism is an uncomfortable aspect of quantum mechanics that even Einstein had trouble
with he famously said God does not play dice about this Randomness but as we'll see God in fact does play dice or in in
our case he flips coins but what's more these coins are loaded measuring a Quantum superposition may be similar to
flipping a coin in some ways but the superposition itself is much richer and more complex than a classical
probabilistic state to see this we're going to think about how a classical coin works and contrast this with our
Quantum coin that we'll explore using kuit on an IBM quantum computer first a classical coin it's
pretty simple you toss the coin and it lands either heads up or heads down with 50% chance of each well in principle we could
calculate which side the coin will land on if we knew the precise initial conditions of the coin and exactly how
much force and torque were applied during the flip but in practice there's no way to know a priority which side the
coin will land on that's why we use the coin flip as a canonical example of a classical probabilistic state where the
outcome is essentially random if I were to flip this coin a thousand times and record the number of heads up
and heads down I would get a histogram that looks something like this so we have counts on the Y
AIS and it could be either heads up or heads down and the
histogram would show that there is about 500 counts of each up to some
statistical fluctuation we can create a similar State using a cubit on our quantum computer like the coin flip a
cubit can also be measured in two possible States zero and one if we apply something called a hadamar gate to the
Cubit it'll put it in an equal superp position of zero and one here's a
visualization of that circuit which we called a circuit diagram here the top wire is the
Cubit and the operations applied to the Cubit show up as boxes on the wires the hadamard gate is shown with this box
labeled H and the measurement is shown with this gray box labeled with the little measurement symbol it sends that
measurement to a classical bit this wire with two lines so since the Cubit is in an equal superposition of 0 and one when
we measure it there will be a 50% chance that we measure zero and 50% we measure
one we express this Quantum superposition State as s = 1 / <
tk2 0 + 1 / < tk2 1 where the squares of each of these
coefficients also called amplitudes are the probabilities of measuring each state so in effect applying the hadamard
gate is the analog to flipping a coin and just like we flipped the coin a thousand times to to look at the
statistics of the coin Landing heads up or heads down we can do something similar on KCET with our Quantum coin
we'll use a kisc primitive called sampler which will repeat the circuit several times to sample the statistics
of the resulting state with a thousand samples of the circuit above we have something that looks basically identical
to the classical coin histogram up to sum statistical fluctuation so is that it quantum
superpositions are essentially the same as a classical probabilistic State akin to flipping a coin not quite this would
be a pretty short video if that were the case to see our first key difference I'm going to try something slightly different with my classical coin instead
of Simply letting it fall onto the table Landing either heads up or down I'm going to toss the coin and catch it
midair between my Palms now the coin is not heads up or down but instead it's either heads left
or right so logic tells us that this two should have a 50/50 probability of being
either heads left or right to measure heads left or right on our Quantum coin we can do what we did with the classical
coin measure along a different AIS our standard measurements on the quantum computer are along the vertical axis
just like the usual heads up or down measurement of the classical coin but we can also ask our Quantum coin if it's
heads left or right we call the these two states along the xais plus or minus
for this we use the kcit Primitive called estimator to complicate things a bit instead of returning a histogram like
sampler does estimator will instead give us the so-called expectation value of any observable of the Cubit to
understand this expectation value let's say you get a dollar every time the coin lands heads up and lose a dollar when it
lands heads down the expectation value is how much money you can expect to earn on average with each coin toss since
you're equally likely to gain or lose a dollar the expectation value would be zero the same reasoning can be applied
to the Cubit when we find the expectation value of x when we apply x to the plus State we
get the value + one and to the minus State we get minus one so if we had a
50/50 distribution we would get an expectation value of zero but we don't we get an expectation value of plus one
meaning the coin is always measured to be plus along the x-axis that would be like flipping a
coin clap catching it and guaranteeing that the head would always be facing to the right this is because a
superposition is not just a probability distribution remember how we express a Quantum
State s is equal to C 0 * the state 0 plus C1
* the state 1 where each of these coefficients are complex meaning they
have both real and imaginary parts so they tell us about the probabilities but they also hide another quantity called
the phase some coefficient C can be written like
this where C equals the magnitude times this phase where this fi is the
phase it's a bit like the phase of a wave or the location of a wave's crests and troughs if two waves are in Phase
with one another so their crests and troughs line up then they'll combine to form a wave twice as
high we call this constructive interference if they're out of phase like
this then they interfere destructively completely canceling each other out to see how the phase can cause
interference in our Quantum coin let's try to apply the hadamard two times instead of just once now classically
this wouldn't make any sense if applying the hadamard is equivalent to flipping a coin then you can't flip a coin that's already flipping but let's see what
happens Quantum mechanically so we apply the hadamard twice and we sample the resulting State
amazingly we no longer have a 50/50 probability the resulting histogram shows that for every case we measure the
Cubit to be in the zero state so the second hadamard has returned the Cubit to the zero state where we started it's
a bit tricky to see at first but this is thanks to the interference of the quantum state but rather than
interfering in real space like an actual wave the interference is happening in abstract information space of the Cubit
the second hadamar gate caused the Zero part of the superposition to interfere constructively while the one part of the
superposition interfere destructively and disappeared let's explore further we can change the phase using
something called a phase gate so now let's PL apply a hadamard to create the superp position apply a phase shift of
Pi radians and then apply the second hadamard now it seems like our Quantum coin always comes out to be in the one
state the pi phase shift exchanged the parts of the superposition state that were in phase and out of phase with one another
so the final state is one instead of zero this would be like flipping a coin and while it's midair being able to
somehow apply an operation that would guarantee that it always landed heads up or always heads down depending on the
operation impossible in the classical case but not in the quantum case what we've learned from these experiments is
that this new capability of the quantum coin is due to its phase a quality that a Quantum superp position has but a
classical probability distribution doesn't so the usual coin flip actually isn't that great of an analogy to a
superposition because it doesn't say anything about this phase I think we can do better I'm going to do another
experiment with our coin I have the coin sitting on the table heads up to make it heads down I can just flip it over this
is the computational equivalent of a not gate say we want to construct an operation that if applied twice would be
equivalent to this knot gate we can call this operation a square root of knot so think about what we're physically doing
when we apply the knot gate we're rotating it 180° around for example the x-axis so if we were to rotate the coin
just 90° around the x-axis that would give us the square root of knot so we've applied
our square root of knot and the coin is just sitting on its Edge now we can ask is it heads up or heads down well
clearly it's neither but we could add a step to the measurement process to force it to be heads up or heads down now the
coin will fall to either heads up or heads down side with equal probability again in principle we could predict
which way it'll fall but in practice this is difficult enough to predict to make it essentially random if I want to
measure whether it's heads left or right I can squash it in that direction and a similar way and it will again give us a
50/50 probability of left and right but in this Dimension heads front or back
the head is already facing forward so 100% of the time we will measure it heads forward so while the x and z
measurements yielded R random results the Y measurement will always yield the same result if we think back to the
quantum coin flip experiment from the previous section this is reminiscent of how the quantum coin behaved after
applying the hadamard the Cubit was measured to be either zero or 1 with 50/50 probability in the Z Direction but
always the plus State and never the minus State along X this suggests that perhaps a coin standing still on its
Edge is a better way to visualize a superposition state of a cubit than a coin wildly flipping through the air
let's apply a square root of knot gate on our Quantum coin in kcit we have this simple
circuit then we'll use estimator to check the expectation value of the three observables X Y and Z which are kind of
like collapsing our coin along each of the three dimensions like I just showed so the expectation values are 0
minus one and 0 for X Y and Z respectively this is the same result we
got for the square root of not rotation applied to the classical coin in fact there's a precise analogy between the
coin and the Cubit State now we can visualize the Cubit State as a vector pointing in the direction of the heads
on the coin normal to the Sur surface of the coin so heads up or the zero State
on the quantum coin is equivalent to a vector pointing straight up heads down or one is pointing straight down and any
equal superposition of 0 and one points horizontally the phase of the quantum State determines the exact horizontal
Direction at points for example whether it's pointing along the xais or along the Y AIS or somewhere in
between this Vector is known as the block vector and it fully and uniquely determines the quantum state of a single
Cubit we can now reimagine every gate that we've seen in this video as a rotation or a series of rotations on the
coin or equivalently on the Block Vector the knot gate is a rotation of
180° around the xais when applied to our zero state or heads up it flips to the
down state or one square root of knot is just 90° around that same xais starting
from the heads up State this rotates it to heads front a phase gate is a rotation of five around the Z axis since
heads up is aligned with the Z axis this doesn't do anything to the coin the hadamar gate is a bit trickier we
initially likened it to flipping a coin making the coin spin uncontrollably in the air but the hadamard is actually a
controlled deterministic rotation of the coin like all the other Gates the hadamard is performed by rotating 90°
around the Y AIS then 180° around the xais so applied to the head's Upstate it
ends up being head's right so there's nothing random about a Quantum superposition state or any of
the standard operation that we perform on the Cubit every operation is deterministic and reversible the only
time Randomness comes into play is when we decide to measure the quantum State whether a Quantum state is even in a
superp position is really just in the eye of the beholder as you've probably encountered we're free to choose our
coordinate system X Y and Z can point along any three orthogonal directions so
if we have a superposition of 0 and one in one coordinate system we can define a new coordinate system or a new so-called
basis in which the state is pointing purely in the plus Z Direction and therefore not in a superposition state
so when we say a cubit is in a super position we must also Define our coordinate system or
basis you may leave this module with the impression that we've just removed all of the mystery from quantum mechanics
after all one of the supposed supposedly weirdest aspects the superposition state of a cubit is really just as simple as a
three-dimensional Vector but keep in mind that the coin is still only an analogy and even the block Vector is
only a visualization tool to calculate the probabilities of the measurement outcomes we can't say what a Quantum
state is really doing before it's measured because checking that requires a measurement we will discuss this
conundrum of what is the true nature of a Quantum State and how the quantum phenomenon of entanglement can help us
elucidate this in another episode of kisd in the classroom all about Bells inequality in the meantime though if you
want to play with Quantum coins to learn for yourself about the superposition states of a cubit and how to control
them head over to the quantum coins module Linked In the description thanks for watching and I'll see you next time